[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit hanna
zimmermann und christian sievers
was nun das ist die große frage über
diesem tag guten abend inhalten wie kann
soll muss europa reagieren das ist die
frage die ich hier gleich auch den
bundeskanzler stellen werde nachdem die
welt jetzt einen russischen präsidenten
erlebt hat der so offen und verstörend
wie nie zuvor gesagt hat was er will
eine geschichtslektion war dass die die
einen paranoid nennen und andere eine
kampfansage
was geht vor in putins kopf auch diese
frage versuchen wir zumindest zu
ergründen in dieser sendung aber erst
der aktuelle stand die lage von
christiansen in moskau
wer glaubt in putins einstündigen
monolog gestern zur ukraine zur
geschichtsdeutung zum westen und zur
nato sei alles gesagt der täuscht sich
heute im kreml pressekonferenz fern paar
ausgewählte russische journalistin und
putin holt in sachen ukraine noch mal
aus
jetzt kommt das wichtigste alles vorher
genannte könnte man sofort
gegenstandslos werden lassen wenn unsere
sogenannten partnern damit fortfahren
die jetzige staatsmacht in kiew mit
modernen waffensystemen auszustatten der
wichtigste punkt ist also in gewissem
sinne die demilitarisierung der heutigen
ukraine
die von ihm angesprochene führung in
kiew muss auf all das reagieren aber wie
während ein soldat beerdigt wird er am
samstag bei gefechten im osten des
landes staat versucht präsident selensky
weiter für ruhe zu sorgen die ukraine
will sich nicht provozieren lassen
es handelt sich um eine neue aggression
gegen die ukraine die eine sofortige und
entschlossene reaktion unsere
internationalen partner und der
internationalen gemeinschaft erfordert
wir glauben dass die russische
föderation mit der entscheidung eine
rechtsgrundlage für weitere militärische
aggression gegen die ukraine schafft
wie diese bilder zeigen sollen sind die
russen längst in den besetzten
separatisten gebieten das behaupten auch
die separatisten selbst verifizieren
lässt sich das nicht
seit gestern nacht feiern sie im don
jetzt die anerkennung ihrer
unabhängigkeit
russland hurra der dank geht nach moskau
für uns ist das sehr wichtig wir wollen
als eine große familie zusammen mit
russland leben ich weiß nicht wie gut
die entscheidung ist und ob sie uns zum
frieden führt
und in kiel versuchen die menschen ruhig
zu bleiben leicht gesagt in diesen tagen
putin will die ganze ukraine alle
sollten das verstehen alle ukraine alle
die in unserem land leben
die angst ist groß jeden tag waren wir
gestern haben wir auf den krieg gewartet
heute warten wir dass er beginnt und das
ist sehr schrecklich im süden russlands
im gebiet roßdorf gibt es
truppenbewegungen richtung separatisten
gebiete russland hat mit der anerkennung
gestern auch militärische unterstützung
zugesagt offiziell aber ist der befehl
noch nicht erfolgt das könnte putin aber
jetzt jederzeit tun es ist die
unberechenbarkeit die putin
perfektioniert hat
genau vor einer woche war
bundeskanzlerin auf scholz noch zum
gespräch bei präsident putin im kreml es
kommt einem vor wie lichtjahre entfernt
guten abend herr bundeskanzler danke
dass sie bei uns sind und
es gibt viele menschen die sich jetzt
große sorgen machen den gestern ein
schauer über den rücken lief als sie
putin hörten eine kriegserklärung war
das sagen manche auch in ihrer koalition
nicht nur die ukraine auch an westliche
werte was haben sie denn gedacht
mir geht es nicht anders als den
bürgerinnen und bürgern das muss uns ja
alle berühren der frieden in europa ist
bedroht ist rot krieg um ein land im
osten europas und das stellt viele
fragen und stellt auch vieles in frage
was wir in den letzten jahren für sicher
geglaubt haben nämlich dass grenzen zum
beispiel in europa nicht mehr verschoben
werden wir können ja alle in die
geschichtsbücher hineingucken und wenn
man da sich historische grenzen anschaut
dann hätte in diesem europa an vielen
stellen jemand an das für grenz
korrekturen und deshalb ist es so
wichtig dass wir uns darauf geeinigt
haben dass die nationale souveränität
nicht in frage gestellt wird und dass
grenzen nicht mehr verschoben werden
putin hat mit der anerkennung dieser
beiden republiken genau das getan und es
ist ein bruch des völkerrechts und das
muss uns auch besorgt machen nicht
besorgt es vor einer woche hatte man
hinterher hatten auch sie hinterher noch
den eindruck die diplomatie könnte eine
chance haben hat putin sie angelogen
es war für mich immer klar dass man sich
keine illusionen machen darf gelesen hat
dass putin schon im letzten jahr
geschrieben hat wer ihm zugehört hat in
den langen gespräch das ich mit ihm
geführt habe aber wer jetzt auch noch
mal hören können was er in seiner
fernsehansprache gesagt hat der weiß
dass hier pläne existieren die wenn sie
alle verwirklicht würden nicht gut sind
für eine friedliche entwicklung in
europa und deshalb war für uns immer
klar dass wir zwei dinge gleichzeitig
tun erstens anzukündigen dass es im fall
der verletzung der territorialen
integrität der souveränität der ukraine
zu sanktionen kommen wird und zweitens
alle möglichen gesprächskanäle zu nutzen
für das was man diplomatisch
voranbringen kann jetzt wo diese
entscheidung gefallen ist sind wir auch
dabei die eine konsequenz zu ziehen
nämlich sanktionen festzusetzen die
genau auf diesen fall zugeschnitten sind
abgestimmt mit den vereinigten staaten
von amerika in zwischen der europäischen
union und den usa hat uns ganz auf die
sanktion kommen wir gleich noch zu
sprechen ich würde gerne noch ein
bisschen kurz bei der frage bleiben
daher viele menschen umtreibt nämlich
was geht in wladimir putin vor ich meine
sie saßen noch vor einer woche
stundenlang ihm gegenüber jetzt sagen
manche zb aus der französischen
regierung das war paranoid was wir
gestern von ihm gehört haben andere
halten ihn für rational können sie
wladimir putin einschätzen
ich versuche mir ein bild zu machen wie
alle anderen das auch tun ich finde man
muss immer auch genau zuhören was jemand
sagt und wenn man genau zuhört dann muss
man leider
erkennen
dass das was er jetzt tut auch zu den
dingen gehört die er schon lange gesagt
hat insofern war es so wichtig die von
mir beschriebene strategie zu verfolgen
zugleich anzukündigen was man tut wenn
es zu aggressionen kommt aber auch alles
zu versuchen das zu verhindern es ist
aus meiner sicht aber durchaus so dass
wir uns da nichts vormachen sollten das
ist eine schwierige und bedrohliche
situation für den frieden aber dieses
drohen mit sanktionen scheint putin ja
überhaupt nicht beeindruckt zu haben
hätte man dann wenn sie sagen man hätte
es schon vorher ahnen können nicht von
anfang an noch drastischer vorgehen
müssen nein ich glaube dass putin weiß
dass wir gut vorbereitet sind dass wir
sehr weit reichende pläne haben für alle
fälle und das darf man ja jetzt an
dieser stelle auch nicht weglassen zu
erwähnen es gibt sehr viele truppen
soldaten kampfverbände die um die
ukraine zurück zusammengezogen worden
sind von russland es wäre jederzeit
möglich noch weiter zu gehen und
tatsächlich an krieg gegen die ganze
ukraine zu führen und deshalb bleibt es
wichtig dass wir neben dem was wir jetzt
an sanktionen auf den weg bringen auch
klar sagen wir haben auch noch weitere
vorbereitet falls es jetzt weitergeht
sind sie denn so sicher dass putin nicht
genau das tut was sie gerade sagen und
noch weiter geht kaum jemand glaubt auch
dass das protein jetzt nach all dem was
passiert ist reicht die gebiete
anzuerkennen in denen seiner armee
ohnehin inoffiziell schon die ganze zeit
war glauben sie nicht dass er am ende
doch mehr möchte
wir dürfen nicht naiv sein und deshalb
habe ich ja eben auch geschildert dass
es wichtig ist genau hinzuhören was er
in den letzten jahren im letzten jahr
aber auch jetzt gesagt hat und
gleichzeitig müssen wir alles dafür tun
dass es eben dazu nicht kommt so weit
ist in unserer macht steht um diese
möglichkeit nutzen wir übrigens in
großer einigkeit was die europäische
union betrifft was die nato betrifft in
großer einigkeit übrigens auch zwischen
den usa und deutschland
gut dann guck mir doch jetzt mal auf die
reaktionen herr bundeskanzler es gibt
durchaus experten die sagen deutschland
und frankreich sind von russland jetzt
am nasenring durch die manege gezogen
worden sehen wir jetzt von jeder seite
aus eine neue deutsche russlandpolitik
eine die möglicherweise konfrontativer
ist
es bleibt bei dem was wir bisher schon
gemacht haben übrigens eng abgestimmt
hintereinander ich habe auch diese woche
wieder diese tage wieder zusammen mit
immer neuen konto beiden telefoniert und
sorgfältig besprochen wie wir gemeinsam
vorgehen und wir wussten immer wie
schwierig und bedrohlich und
beängstigend die situation ist wir
wussten aber immer dass wir unsere
möglichkeiten nutzen müssen und eben die
die wir haben und das sind die die ich
schon genannt habe und da gehen wir
diesen weg auch konsequent herr
bundeskanzler kurz unterbrechen darf die
frage ist ja so ein bisschen das minsker
abkommen auf das sie vor einer woche
noch viele hoffnungen setzen das ist
jetzt mit dem gestrigen abend de facto
am ende worüber wollen sie denn ganz
konkret verhandeln oder anders gefragt
auf welcher basis wollen sie verhandeln
mit putin sie haben recht das minsker
abkommen ist von putin gebrochen worden
und das bleibt ein fakt den wir hier
gemeinsam feststellen müssen und deshalb
ist es trotzdem wichtig
weiter zu kommen auf dem weg den wir
haben aber das erste was wir jetzt
machen ist damit wir auch richtig
verstanden werden das umzusetzen was wir
angekündigt haben und deshalb habe ich
mich sehr darum bemüht das möglichst
noch heute eine entscheidung der eu über
das notwendige sanktionspaket passiert
weiterkommen sagen sie das verstehe ich
noch nicht so ganz was heißt denn jetzt
konkret weiterkommen haben sie den
eindruck dass putin irgendwann sagen
könnte okay das mit der anerkennung der
sogenannten volksrepublik das war ein
fehler das nämlich jetzt wieder zurück
haben sie den eindruck auf gar keinen
fall gehe zurück stellen darf auch das
alter häufig ist es so dass jeder
genügend realismus hat diese situation
einzuschätzen sie unsere zuschauerinnen
und zuschauer alle bürgerinnen und
bürger in diesem land auch die
bundesregierung und alle unsere
verbündeten und deshalb ist es ja so
wichtig dass wir zusammenstehen und dass
wir uns sorgfältig abgesprochen haben
über das was zu tun ist weil wir uns
eben keine illusionen machen dürfen aber
weil wir gleichzeitig auch niemals
aufgeben dürfen alles dafür zu versuchen
dass wir es hinbekommen dass dieser
fahrt wieder verlassen wird dass das
schwierig ist macht ihre frage zu recht
deutlich aber das darf uns ja nicht
davon abhalten diesen schwierigen fahrt
auch zu gehen ok jetzt also sanktionen
sie haben heute nord stream 2 gestoppt
das war vielleicht das größte faustpfand
das deutschland gegenüber russland in
der hand hatte wie sie das gemacht haben
das klingt jetzt sehr kompliziert
verwaltungstechnisch und auch
einigermaßen bürokratisch deswegen frage
ich mal ganz einfach damit wir es
verstehen hat denn diese pipeline für
die zukunft überhaupt noch eine chance
voraussetzung für die inbetriebnahme der
pipeline ist das versorgungssicherheit
in europa gewährleistet ist dazu gibt es
einen bericht den das
wirtschaftsministerium im letzten jahr
gefertigt hat und nach all den
entwicklungen der letzten tage kann man
ja nicht mehr sagen dass wir auf diesen
bericht weiter aufbauen können deshalb
wird es an neuen geben und mit dem
werden wir uns sehr viel mühe geben und
er wird genau diese fragen beinhalten
und da muss man schon sagen das ist
jetzt erst mal eine sache die nicht
weiter vorangehen aber erstmal da höre
ich das wort erst mal dass die pipeline
bleibt weiter existent und könnte auch
wieder ans netz gehen verspricht wieder
richtig realistisch ist es nicht so dass
da jetzt die dinge so vorankommen dass
das jemand hier vorher sagen würde ich
jedenfalls würde mich da nicht auf eine
wippe einlassen aber sie sagen jetzt
nicht das war's mit nord stream 2 für
alle zeiten wir haben dieses verfahren
so auf den weg gebracht wie ich eben
beschrieben habe und das ist eine sehr
entschiedene maßnahmen von der ich
übrigens höre dass sie überall bei
unseren freunden und verbündeten europa
und nordamerika in der ganzen
transatlantischen allianz gut verstanden
worden ist und auch viel unterstützung
bekommt die drohung mit sanktionen hat
wladimir putin bislang nicht beeindruckt
ja sagt er aber das alles eingepreist
hat er gestern gesagt was wenn ihnen
auch die sanktionen selbst nicht
beeindrucken
dann müssen wir weiter beharrlich auf
dem bestehen dass wir richtig finden das
ist ja das was wir können und wir können
ja nicht gleichzeitig die illusion
erwecken dass es einen knopf gibt auf
den bedrückten können und dann wird
alles anders kommen die welt ist so
schwierig dass wir uns darauf einlassen
müssen mit dieser neuen veränderten und
bedrohlichen situationen umzugehen und
dazu ist geschlossenheit und klarheit
erforderlich die haben wir der
bundeskanzler in einer schwierigen
weltwirtschaftlichen danke das gespräch
heute abend dem heute schon mal einen
schönen guten abend und
das gespräch haben aus termingründen vor
zwei stunden aufgezeichnet der
bundeskanzler hat die antwort der
europäer mehrfach angesprochen wie sie
im detail aussieht und was die
opposition in berlin von alledem hält
fasst thomas reiter zusammen
vor der russischen botschaft in berlin
demonstrieren heute abend rund 600
menschen schwenken ukrainische fahnen
fordern von russland eine stopp der
militärischen aggression ein paar
stunden zuvor ganz in der nähe im
kanzleramt olaf scholz wird vladimir
putin einen bruch des völkerrechts vor
der konsequenzen haben müsse eine davon
das vorläufige aus der umstrittenen
pipeline nord stream 2
ich habe das
bundeswirtschaftsministerium heute
gebeten den bestehenden bericht zur
analyse der versorgungssicherheit bei
der bundesnetzagentur zurückzuziehen das
klingt zwar technisch ist aber der
nötige verwaltungsrechtliche schützt
damit jetzt keine zertifizierung der
pipeline erfolgen kann scholz hat diese
parteien lange als rein
privatwirtschaftliches projekt
bezeichnet und es vermieden ihren namen
bei möglichen sanktionen auch nur zu
nennen nun kündigt er an das
genehmigungsverfahren werde neu bewertet
und das könne dauern es ist ein
einschnitt wie kiefer geht zeigt sich
auch daran keine kritik heute dazu von
der union und die bundesregierung hat
sehr abgewogen behandelt sie hat die
volle unterstützung der cdu csu
bundestagsfraktion bei ihrem gut
abgestimmten vorgehen der west muss
jetzt zusammenstehen europa aber auch
die deutsche politik sollte sich hinter
der bundesregierung versammeln
die linke die eine drohende invasion
russlands lange für kriegs getrommelt
des westens hielt distanziert sich nun
erst mal von sich selbst dass sahra
wagenknecht dort und besonderer weise
auf die vergangenheit und die ausdehnung
der nato in richtung russland verwiesen
hat es korrekt aber dass sie geleugnet
hat dass diese gefahr besteht das sieht
man heute stimmt nicht auf eu ebene sind
sie sich am nachmittag schnell einig die
frage ab wann putin die rote linie
überschritten habe wann sanktionen
greifen sollen stellt sich nun nicht
mehr
man hat die ukraine angegriffen indem
man diese republiken anerkannt hat indem
man jetzt deutlich macht man werde die
republiken sichern auch sichern mit
militär und darauf müssen wir jetzt eine
ganz klare antwort geben wochenlang hat
die gut diese antwort vorbereitet in
paris beschließen die außenminister
erste sanktionen gegen banken
finanzmärkte und den russland handel sie
sollen putin die finanzierung seiner
politik erschweren
jesus sanktionspaket das von den
mitgliedsstaaten einstimmig angenommen
wurde wird russland weh tun und zwar
sehr hält
wir tun das in starker abstimmung mit
unseren partnern den usa großbritannien
und kanada
olaf scholz warnt heute putin warte auf
einen vorwand um möglicherweise die
gesamte ukraine zu besetzen in berlin in
europa herrscht fassungslosigkeit über
die kühe geplante aggression aus moskau
entscheidend für die weitere entwicklung
ist die frage wo russland künftig
grenzen ziehen will da sollten wir uns
jetzt mal auf der karte anschauen das
sind die beiden jetzt von russland an
erkannten separatisten gebiet wir sehen
die faktische kontrolle hat die
russische seite nur über einen teil des
gebiets bis zur international
festgelegten sogenannten
kontakt linie hier rot dort gab es auch
bislang schon russische soldaten jetzt
dann möglicherweise auch offiziell die
separatisten beanspruchen aber deutlich
mehr nämlich die gesamten ukrainischen
bezirke lohans und dann jetzt wird
russland also weiter vorstoßen ist die
frage an axel sturm zunächst in kiew
axel wie ist die lage
ja es war heute den ganzen tag sehr
ruhig um den ukrainischen präsidenten
selensky aber kurz vor dieser sendung
ist er dann doch vor die kameras
getreten und hat eine sehr patriotische
rede gehalten die kern nachricht ist
wenn wir heute schweigen sind wir morgen
verschwunden daran merkt man vielleicht
auch wie emotional die situation hier
diskutiert wird zielinski hat die
reservisten einberufen er sagt es
handele sich nicht um eine
generalmobilmachung aber die reservisten
müssten eingezogen werden um die
truppenstärke der ukraine zu verstärken
und aus dem don was erreichen uns
irritierende nachrichten nachrichten die
schwer zu überprüfen sind wacklige handy
bilder von militär transporten von
raketenbeschuss aber wohin diese
fahrzeuge fahren und wohin diese raketen
fliegen das lässt sich im moment kaum
verifizieren
danke axel der us-präsident befürchtet
weiter einen groß angelegten russischen
angriff auf die ukraine matti wissen
welche sanktionen hat er denn heute
abend angekündigt
ja sehr harte sanktionen vor allem gegen
zwei der größten bank in russland die
für den internationalen zahlungsverkehr
des landes wichtig sind dann aber auch
ein verbot des kaufs von russischen
staatsanleihen und direkte sanktionen
gegen eliten unmittelbar im umfeld von
wladimir putin einschließlich des
einfrierens ihrer guthaben im ausland
das sei aber nur ein erster schritt so
sagte der us-präsident wenn bloody mia
putin seine aggression vorantreibe dann
wäre dann einen noch viel höheren preis
zahlen
zitat beiden ich glaube er will weiter
gehen ich hoffe dass ich da falsch liege
aber man glaubt im weißen haus dass es
tatsächlich weitergeht und deswegen
schickt der us-präsident zusätzliche
soldaten in das baltikum und f 35
kampfflugzeugen werden jetzt aus
deutschland an die nato ostflanke
verlegt das alles sein aber defensive
maßnahmen sagt joe biden noch einmal
zitat wir haben keinerlei absicht gegen
russland zu kämpfen
also die hoffnung auf eine diplomatische
lösung die tendiert hier in washington
gegen null und das treffen zwischen lauf
und blinken das für morgen geplant war
das steht zumindest in den sternen
vielen dank an die kollegen in kiew und
in washington ja jeder konflikt kennt
gewinn lag aber vor allem viele die
verlieren auch wenn sie weit entfernt
vom krisengebiet leben europa ist
abhängig von russischem gas deutschland
ganz besonders wenn die energiepreise
steigen wie aktuell ja bereits enorm
dann trifft das verbraucher und
industrie was die industrie trifft die
bereits jetzt alarm schlägt das trifft
dann auch wieder uns alle und auch die
sanktionen haben ihren preis nicht nur
für russland erklärt karl hinterleitner
nord stream zwei droht das aus nach
langem zögern heute die entscheidung die
pipeline ist auf eis gelegt eine
betriebserlaubnis für die gasleitung
wird vorerst nicht erteilt der
wirtschaft und den verbrauchern in
deutschland könnte das noch stürmische
zeiten bescheren
bundeswirtschaftsminister habig wurde
heute morgen deutlich
mit einer gewissen vermutung wird es
auch auswirkungen auf die gaspreise
haben einfach weil märkte spekulations
anfällig sind und die preise eben auch
immer eine wette auf die zukunft und
wenn die zukunft ungewisser ist ist zu
befürchten dass die preise nach oben
gehen wie zur bestätigung kam kurz
darauf die reaktion des früheren
russischen präsidenten mitglieder
herzlich willkommen in einer neuen welt
wo die europäer bald schon 2000 euro pro
kubikmeter gas zahlen werden
das wäre eine preis explosion die aber
halten wirtschaftsexperten für wenig
realistisch denn die abhängigkeit ist
gegenseitig deutschland braucht das gas
russland braucht die einnahmen
dass die russische regierung und die
russische elite darauf auch verbal
reagiert man muss dazu sagen aber
eigentlich auch nicht leisten kann die
europäer oder den europäischen markt
komplett zu vergraulen
die deutsche wirtschaft ist besorgt über
die verschärfung der lage man habe
ökonomisch mit russland immer noch eine
gute zusammenarbeit und hofft auf die
eskalation
die deutsche wirtschaft bedauert diese
politische entwicklung außerordentlich
die sind natürlich eine große belastung
für die deutsch-russischen
wirtschaftsbeziehungen die sich gerade
im letzten jahr und anfang dieses jahres
sehr sehr positiv entwickelt haben und
wir müssen abwarten welche
sanktionsmechanismen gegebenenfalls in
kraft gesetzt werden und was das für
unsere künftigen wirtschaftsbeziehung
bedeutet und die eu hat heute weitere
sanktionen beschlossen so soll die
russische staatsbank kein geld mehr im
westen leihen könne vermögen von
unternehmen und personen auf der
sanktionsliste zb abgeordneten werden
eingefroren die wirkung ungewiss
forschung
also dass zwei drittel der funktion
nicht das ziel erreichen deswegen es
wird sich sicherlich ausdrücken ob es
einen politikwechsel erwirken wird ist
eher zweifelhaft aber nicht unmöglich
das hofft man zumindest in deutschland
und europa es ist das hoffen auf
mäßigung im letzten moment
mehr noch als die sanktionen könnte dem
russischen präsidenten das zu schaffen
machen was gerade an den heimischen
börsen passiert und mit der eigenen
währung beide frank bethmann waren auf
talfahrt ja der russische aktienmarkt
zuletzt förmlich abgerauscht 20 prozent
verlust in nur vier tagen heute morgen
noch auf einem 52 wochen tief besonders
finanztitel unter druck wie russlands
größte bank die sberbank die zuletzt
gleich um 30 prozent eingebrochen war
ähnliches beim rubel zu beobachten
vormittags auf dem tiefsten stand seit
15 monaten
und dann auf einmal die gegenbewegung im
übrigen nicht nur bei rubel und
russischen aktien das konnten wir heute
fast überall beobachten auch hier in
frankfurt erst deutliche verluste dann
ging es wieder rauf mit den kursen und
warum das heißt dass die börsen haben
die situation jetzt quasi schon
eingepreist weil sie mit einer noch
brisanteren entwicklung gerechnet hatten
ja sagt man ja immer so schön es hätte
vereinfacht gesprochen schlimmer kommen
können die sanktionen hätten durchaus
härter ausfallen können so die meinung
hier die börsianer argumentieren die kuh
ist noch nicht vom eis doch trotz der
aktuell unklaren situation und den
kursschwankungen seien die aussichten
für die kapitalmärkte mittelfristig
weiter gut die deutsche wirtschaft wäre
es ja eben schon gehört weit weniger
optimistisch der ukraine konflikt sei
gift für den aufschwung
frank herzlichen dank für diese analyse
leider aus frankfurt hat jetzt die
gretchenfrage vielleicht was geht vor in
wladimir putin was treibt ihn wie denkt
er nicht nur für kreml beobachter sind
das aufreibende zeiten da ließ der
präsident gestern seinen nationalen
sicherheitsrat antreten im kreml also
die wenigen übrig gebliebenen im zentrum
der macht denen er noch sein ohr schenkt
und zwingt einen nach dem anderen dazu
seinen kurs zu unterstützen ausweichende
antworten akzeptiert putin nicht um zu
spüren wer hier das sagen hat muss man
kein russlandexperte seien nicht mal
russisch können
es reicht sich den gefürchteten chef des
auslandsgeheimdienstes sergej naryschkin
anzusehen wie ein nervös nach worten
sucht und von beatle zurechtgewiesen
wird
[Musik]
bis in die erste linie
bei
dieser richtung ist
der herrscher im kreml und seine sicht
der dinge dominik löschmeister stellt
dem die historischen fakten gegenüber
im mittelalter war kiew die hauptstadt
des osmanischen reiches wie russland und
belarus versteht sich die ukraine als
nachfolgestaat der historischen kiew
akkus die von der ostsee bis zum
schwarzen meer reichte
russland und die ukraine prägt eine
gemeinsame geschichte aber sind russen
und ukrainer deswegen 1 wie es putin
behauptet nein sagt der historiker aus
meiner sicht ist das eine geschichts
mystifikation sehen sie deutschland und
frankreich haben ja zum beispiel auch
einen gemeinsamen ursprung im
frankenreich mittelalter aber niemand in
frankreich kämen doch auf die idee
deutschland die nationalstaatlichkeit
abzusprechen
jahrhunderte lang standen die ukraine
unter fremdherrschaft von russland polen
oder österreich ungarn im zarenreich war
die ukrainische sprache verboten
im ersten weltkrieg ließ der deutsche
kaiser truppen in der ukraine
einmarschieren mit dem ende des ersten
weltkriegs entsteht nur kurz ein
ukrainischer nationalstaat der dann
unter linien teil der sowjetunion wird
stalin ist 1932 verantwortlich für eine
entsetzliche hungersnot in der ukraine
mindestens 3,5 millionen menschen
sterben holodomor eine politik der
vernichtung das äußerte sich nicht nur
in dieser gezielt herbeigeführten
hungersnot
dreißiger jahre sondern auch in
kampagnen gegen kritische intellektuelle
also es gegen stalin eindeutig darum
ukrainische identität zurückzudrängen
und von der sowjetischen völlig zu
überlagern
putin verschweigt dieses verbrechen an
dem ukrainischen volk in seiner rede er
sieht nur den verfall der alten so wird
1991 erklärt die ukraine wie andere teil
staaten ihre unabhängigkeit
drei jahre später verzichtet kiew im
budapester memorandum sogar auf
atomwaffen die gefahr für putin er
westorientierung und demokratie das hat
mehrere demokratische regierungswechsel
in der ukraine gegeben
das unterscheidet da ihnen heute wieder
von putins russland wo ein machtwechsel
durch wahlen ja überhaupt nicht mehr
vorstellbar ist putins interpretation
der geschichte ein versuch eine
aggressive politik zu rechtfertigen
gegen das völkerrecht und gegen die
unabhängigkeit der ukraine
die vergangenheit ändert sich ständig
lautete ein altes sowjetisches
sprichwort ein radio eriwan witz der
heute wieder sehr aktuell ist im
heute-journal update gegen 0 uhr 10
spricht nach sein gibt er mir mit
manfred weber dem chef der konservativen
svp fraktion im europaparlament eine
frage wem schadet das aus von nord
stream zwei mehr russland oder
deutschland nur 10 jetzt aber erstmal
weitere wichtige nachrichten von diesem
tag gebündelt von diana und da ist
corona thema genauer der korona pflege
bonus der schon lange erwartet wird
jetzt hat bundesgesundheitsminister
lauterbach dazu konkrete pläne vorgelegt
eine milliarde euro sollen ausgezahlt
werden die eine hälfte an krankenhäuser
die andere an pflegeeinrichtungen laut
eckpunktepapier sollen beschäftigte in
der altenpflege einen einmaligen bonus
bekommen von maximal 550 euro in
krankenhäusern soll individuell über die
höhe der prämie entschieden werden die
stiftung patientenschutz kritisiert den
bonus als zu niedrig und
der blick auf die korona zahlen zeigt
die neue infektionen gehen deutlich
zurück das robert koch institut
registrierte
125 1902 neue fälle das sind über 33.000
weniger als vor einer woche auch die
sieben tage incidents ist weiter rückt
häufig sie liegt nun bei
1300 6,3
306 todesfälle kamen dazu
österreich lockert seine
einreisebestimmungen und lässt seit
heute wieder ungeimpfte ins land
voraussetzung ist allerdings ein
negativer corona test der schritt gilt
vor allem in der tourismusbranche als
wichtig die nun auf möglichst viele
urlaubsgäste hofft ab dem fünften märz
sollen dann praktisch alle corona
maßnahmen in österreich wegfallen die
masken pflicht bleibt aber bestehen
in deutschland gibt es bereits ein
lieferketten gesetz nun will die
eu-kommission nachziehen mit einer noch
strengeren regelung laut dem
gesetzentwurf sollen größere unternehmen
in zukunft für die praktiken ihrer
zulieferer in die pflicht genommen
werden dabei geht es zum beispiel um
menschenrechtsverletzungen oder verstöße
gegen den umweltschutz geplant ist dies
für firmen mit mehr als 500 mitarbeitern
in bestimmten branchen bereits ab 250
beschäftigten zum vergleich das deutsche
lieferketten gesetz gilt zunächst nur
für unternehmen mit mehr als 3000
mitarbeitern
wer sein haus energetisch sanieren
möchte der kann ab heute wieder einen
förderantrag bei der kfw stellen ende
januar war die förderung abrupt gestoppt
worden weil die gelder dafür
aufgebraucht waren nach massiver kritik
hat die bundesregierung reagiert und 9,5
milliarden euro zusätzlich
bereitgestellt
auch die förderung von
energieeffizienten neubauten nach dem e
h 40 standard soll bald wieder
aufgenommen werden allerdings unter
geänderten bedingungen
im westafrikanischen burkina faso gab es
eine explosion an einer goldmine
mindestens 63 menschen sind ums leben
gekommen weitere 70 wurden teilweise
schwer verletzt die behörden vermuten
dass sich illegal gelagerter sprengstoff
in einer goldwaschanlage entzündet hat
die mine war offenbar nicht zugelassen
in burkina faso kommt es immer wieder zu
solchen unglücken das kaum
sicherheitsvorkehrungen gibt der abbau
von gold hat sich zum wichtigsten
exportgut des landes entwickelt
und das war dieser dienstag im
heute-journal danke dass sie mit uns
dabei waren und gegen 0.10 gibt's dann
unser heute schon mal update wir
wünschen ihnen einen schönen abend
[Musik]
einführung genannte und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter hoher luftdruck
macht's möglich viel sonnenschein gibt
es morgen im tagesverlauf aber noch
haben wir es mit einem tief zu tun steve
ihr richtung nordsee muss ich erst
einmal verlagern und dann lockert es
allmählich auf und auch der schnee an
den alpen lässt nach die details in der
nacht gibt es regen und schnee oberhalb
von 700 metern zum beispiel richtung
erzgebirge oder an den alpen sonst
lockert es auf der wind weht aus
nordwestlichen richtungen uns teilweise
stürmisch ja und richtung westen da wird
es klart auf den straßen denn es klart
auf die temperaturen sinken auf null bis
minus ein grad ganz im südwesten
deutschlands sind es sechs grad morgen
tagesverlauf also viel sonne vor allem
richtung rhein und an der see in den
östlichen landesteilen gibt es kompakte
wolken bis es fast überall trocken im
süden lassen regen und schneeschauer
allmählich nach bei höchsten
temperaturen von sieben bis neun grad
teils 12 grad richtung niederrhein und
14 grad am oberrhein die kommenden tage
am donnerstag wird es vor allem im
nordwesten stürmig sein aus
südwestlichen richtungen dazu kommen
viele wolken auf das ist eine kaltfront
die aufzieht und sich langsam nach
südosten verlagert sonst gibt's
sonnenschein höchste werte vor der
kaltfront bis 16 grad danach ist aber
deutlich kühler dann haben wir es am
freitag mit regen schnee und
graupelschauern und teilt sogar
gewittern zu tun damit ein schöner abend